criminal justice the war on drugs and
incarceration are going to be major
question marks during the Donald Trump
administration and presidency and for
today's classic interview were going
back to October of 2013 my interview
with Professor Todd clear this is one of
the best interviews we've done about the
issues with and origins of the
incarceration status quo that we have in
the United States the United States
really really uh unimportant for
background to understand when we think
about what should the United States be
doing going forward when it comes to the
war on drugs putting people in prison
jail etc so with no further delay let's
get to my interview with Todd clear from
October 17th of 2013 I'm joined by Todd
clear who is the Dean of the School of
criminal justice at Rutgers University
also author of 12 books including
imprisoning communities really great to
have you on today you know we've been
talking about incarceration quite a bit
on this program over the years and I've
kind of been focusing on three issues
and what I would love to do is tell you
what they are and then you tell me if
you think I'm missing some key issues
that were that I'm not talking about
when it comes to incarceration one has
been incarceration in conjunction with
the war on drugs and the
disproportionate effect it has on
minorities number two has been how
private prisons including the ownership
stakes in them by big Wall Street firms
has furthered unproductive legislation
in terms of detention of nonviolent drug
offenders as well as undocumented
immigrants and then three has been
solitary confinement and just the
disastrous the feds astris effects that
it can have on individuals and really
set them up to never again be so-called
productive members of society so
evaluate my coverage of prisons and tell
me are these important issues what am I
missing so the so the drug war is a key
you know in 1976 about three percent of
the people who are incarcerated where
drug charges and about less than ten
percent of people entering prison came
in on drug charges today it's about a
third and about half of the people who
come into prison and that's been
entirely produced not by changes in drug
use but it changes in sentencing and the
way we sentence people who get convicted
for possession of drugs and it used to
be rare that a person who was caught
with with a controlled substance went to
prison it's now the rule rather than the
exception so that's that is a key the
private prison industry is interesting
but only about fifteen percent of the
prisoners nationally are in some sort of
private facility so it's not the main
engine driving incarceration rates
incarceration rates are entirely
produced by two numbers how many people
go to prison and how long they stay and
we've been increasing the rate of people
going to prison and increasing the
length of stay in prison for almost 40
years and and the private prison
industry has has been a beneficiary of
growing force populations has created a
market but they have not been a driver
now there have been some states that
have experimented or thought about
experimenting with large increases in
private incarceration like Arizona and
that would be an enormous mistake you'd
create a permanent lobby for growing
prison populations but that really that
really doesn't exist in any in any
meaningful way in the states not that
they're not that there's there are
plenty of issues about a private
incarceration that I think we could pay
attention to but they're not a main
driver of mass incarceration really what
has driven the incarceration growth the
United States has been changes in the
way we sentence people in 1972 about
three quarters of the people who were
convicted of a felony got sentenced to
probation today about three-quarters get
sentenced to prison so that's been cut
by third by two-thirds in 1972 the
median length of stay of a sentence was
about 15 months it's now about 30 months
so you can understand why you have a
prison population that is so much larger
there even though
crime rate is about what it was in 1972
that's because we sent a lot more people
to prison and we make them stay there
longer if you had to pick the specific
battle to fight that you think would
have the biggest positive impact on the
kind of status quo of incarceration in
the US is it where at where would you
attack it if you could only focus on one
area it'd be a tough call between
changing sentencing for people convicted
of drug crimes and eliminating mandatory
minimum sentences both of those have
contributed their own enormous piece to
the math problem mass incarceration but
and they're related because some of the
mandatory minimum sentences are from
drug crimes but they are targeting a
slide if enough different group that you
could do something about if you said
nobody can go to prison for possession
of drugs you would have an impact on
mass incarceration but it would be
smaller than you would think because
people who go to prison for possession
of drugs tend to stay there not very
long a mandatory minimum sentences on
the other hand are quite significant
because not only are you not being
placed on probation but you're also
typically being sensed too much longer
than the judge would ordinarily impose
so mandatory minimums in the federal
system for example or 10 20 and 30 years
and if you eliminated those and allowed
judicial discretion for choosing
sentences lower than those mandatory
minimums you would have a significant
impact so be tough call between those
two I take either one of those if you
force my hand i would say that there is
a mandatory minimum sentence to prison
is not allowed and if that were always
the case that a person could make that
you could make a case for a
community-based penalty for any person
convicted of any crime i think or a
lesser sentence than well then what the
law provides is a maximum for any crime
I think you'd have more impact on mass
incarceration jovi if we went back to
the sentencing laws of 1980 within a
very few years we would have the prison
population of 1980 if we put aside just
for a second the the disproportionate
application of on minorities
when we look at these mandatory minimums
drug crimes we look at higher drug usage
rates among whites but higher
incarceration rates for drug usage among
minorities putting that aside just
briefly let's imagine that weren't the
problem I get emails from people on both
sides of the political spectrum saying
listen we understand all of the the this
this minority disproportionate stuff but
when you put people in prison they
aren't committing crimes so it is still
better for the surrounding community is
that even true can we even still can we
even say that accurately yeah and the
answer that is increasingly it's
becoming clear that that is not a not a
meaningful argument used to be that it's
a penance and you know makes sense on
the face you lock a person up that
person can't commit crimes but there are
two mechanisms that really reduce the
that's usually called the incapacitation
effect of a prison sentence one is
replacement most crimes that are
committed in communities are committed
by young men and groups and if you
incarcerate one person from that group
you may have no impact on the group's
level of criminal activity in other
words the number of crimes that actually
get committed and what you may do
actually is open up a place for someone
else to join in who might not have been
involved in that criminal network now
become involved this is particularly
true drug-related crimes you don't when
you lock up a person for selling drugs
you don't prevent a single drug from
being sold you just create a job opening
for somebody else to sell drugs and when
you do this in a framework where there
are lots of guns you create not only a
job for selling drugs but also you armed
somebody who might not be armed so you
can see why and this is by the way to
for burglaries many robberies lots of
car thefts a lot of the kinds of crimes
that that we are very worried about in
urban environments are created by are
committed by people in groups and
incarcerated individuals doesn't do much
about that rate that's how come we can
have a six-fold increase in the number
of people locked up today as compared to
the 1970s and yet still have the same
crime rate we have the 1970s is there
some all other intangible detriment that
also takes place because you're breaking
families up and
kind of changing the the social dynamics
of the neighborhood could we say
something about that as well well that
was the other thing I was going to say
that that we now know that sending a
person first of all incarceration
concentrates itself significantly in a
small number of communities so that for
example in Chicago two-thirds of the
people go to prison come from seven of
the neighborhoods in Chicago that kind
of thing and there are neighborhoods
where the rates are so high that as many
as one fourth of the adult men are
locked up on any given day but the
people who are locked up change from day
to day so some people are released from
prison and come back and other people
are removed from the community to go to
prison what that means is that you have
a neighborhood in which men are not
stable a stable part of neighborhood
environment so let me just lay out a few
statistics we know that going to prison
reproduces your lifetime earnings by
forty percent if you come if you're a
child coming from a neighborhood where
most men go to prison at some time you
come from a neighborhood where men have
forty percent less earning power meaning
that there is forty percent less money
to spend on you as a child to produce
businesses in that community to increase
economic activity to make sure that
homes are taken care of to buy the
things that kids need to go to school on
and on and on we also know that having a
parent go to prison reduces your chances
of being involved as a child reduces
your chances of being involved on the
juvenile justice system I'm sorry I mean
to say that again we know that going to
prison increases the chances of a child
going to the juvenile justice system by
one-fourth so when you have a community
in which every child is connected to an
adult who's been to prison you have a
community in which all those children
are more vulnerable to to the juvenile
justice system being arrested we also
know that that increases the chance of a
physical health problems we know that
increases the chance of emotional
problems we know for example that in
neighborhoods where lots of people are
cycling in and out of the prison system
sexually transmitted diseases are much
better much higher rate because in
intimate relationships between men and
women have been destabilized so if you
add all these things up together you get
a situation in which incarceration
policies which have dramatically
increased the number of people going to
prison from
inner-city neighborhoods have the impact
of making those neighborhoods less
stable and and and increasing the level
of the contribute contributors to
criminality in those neighborhoods
that's why you can have nationally a
drop in crime rate but in some
neighborhoods the crime rate stays very
stubbornly high and it's partly because
incarceration has made it hard for those
neighborhoods to develop the kind of
stable social patterns that really
produce Public Safety yes and not only
do we have to look at the kind of
cultural and punitive and rehabilitative
aspects of these prison sentences but
their significant economic aspects as
well over overtime to these
neighborhoods we've been speaking with
Todd clear he's the Dean of the School
of criminal justice at Rutgers
University author of 12 books including
imprisoning communities really great to
speak to you today thank you